this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies this piece of paper looks
about as white as white can get but what
if I told you the color white doesn't
exist do you really expect me to believe
that now without an explanation
obviously okay so the reason we can see
anything at all is because of light so
let's start there the word light applies
to anything on the e/m spectrum these
category names are adjectives radio
light infrared light ultraviolet light
the universe is full of light it's just
that we can't see most of it the only
type of light we can see is this little
tiny sliver right here which we call
visible light
for obvious reasons we see almost none
of the light in the universe but we do
see enough to you know function on a
daily basis I mean the vast majority of
light emitted by the Sun is visible so
it shouldn't be that surprising that
animals evolved to see light in or near
this range seeing in x-rays or radio
just wouldn't be that useful anyway is
specific colors are kind of like
subcategories if we zoom in on the
visible part of the spectrum we can see
how the frequency or wavelength of light
corresponds to color do you see any
white in there I don't check mate white
does not exist how the heck is your lab
coat white then okay I suppose I could
elaborate sure we assign colors to each
of these wavelengths but does that mean
these wavelengths are those colors there
are plenty of colors we can see that
don't correspond to a single wavelength
of light black white and magenta are
three big examples so clearly there's
more to color than just light hmm well
we know light is necessary without it
all we see is black black is the absence
of light so we definitely need a source
of light like the Sun or a bulb or
something then we need the thing we're
trying to see and then our eyeballs and
then our brains this is getting
overwhelming let's look at this as one
big process lots of light is emitted by
the Sun some of that light will reflect
off of this leaf
even less if that light actually enters
your eyes which then sends signals to
your brain which in turn has to
interpret those signals let's start with
that reflection remember the Sun emits
all the colors in the visible spectrum
the reason this leaf looks green is
because that's the color the leaf
reflects let me repeat that for everyone
in the back objects do not have color
light has color objects just absorb some
colors and reflect others I'm totally
serious my phone case isn't red it just
reflects red light if you put it under
different colored light it'll be a
different color if something looks white
that just means it reflects all the
colors but that can also happen with
things that are transparent take a nice
piece of plastic for example you might
be inclined to say it doesn't have color
it's clear but if you fold it enough
times you'll notice something weird
it'll start to turn white
this happens because transparent
materials aren't perfect there's always
a little reflection if there's only one
layer of plastic the reflection is
insignificant but every fold adds extra
reflections eventually most of the light
gets reflected instead of passing
through the same thing happens with
polar bear fur it's also transparent
it's just that the fur is layered enough
with air to maximize reflections you can
turn the reflection back down a bit by
filling the air spaces with something
else like water which is exactly how the
wet t-shirt effect works
the point is objects don't have color
light does the next step in the process
is how our eyes actually respond to that
light it's time for a crash course in
human eye biology the inside back of the
eye is covered in cells called
photoreceptors cells which literally
means light receiver it's kind of nice
when a scientific name actually makes
sense
those photoreceptor cells come in two
types rods and cones which is literally
a description of their shape the rods
only detect intensity of light so there
are really useful for color vision the
cones are where the magic happens at the
top of each cone is a stack of membrane
teeny-tiny collections of a protein
called this is another protocol it
transducin this
he's raised a secondary messenger
chemical in the Cullens cytoplasm to a
decrease and cgmp close us so hyper fold
we call this basic what what what what
okay here's what actually matters light
hits the cones in a chemical process
sends a signal to the brain that signal
contains information about color because
there are three different types of cones
red green and blue they're not actually
that color most things in the human body
are roughly the same pinkish brown color
these types of cones are called red
green and blue cones because that's the
type of light they each respond to wait
wait our eyes can only see red green and
blue yeah pretty much then how does our
brain know about the other colors mixed
signals this is one of those rare cases
when mixed signals are a good thing if
you map out the sensitivity of the cone
cells against the visible spectrum you
get something like this now let's say
orange light enters your eye that light
will activate the red cones and the
green cones by a very specific amount
which sends a unique mixed signal to the
brain no other color creates that signal
combination the same is true for every
other color on the visible spectrum but
here's the thing there are signal
combinations the brain can receive that
aren't created by a single wavelength of
light what if the blue and red cones
activate intensely at the same time none
of the colors on the visible spectrum
are gonna do that but if your brain gets
that signal it's got to make sense of it
somehow so it makes it look like this
magenta your brain literally made up a
color for a hypothetical signal
combination and that's not the only
color it made up what if all three types
of cones activate intensely at the same
time well that's what your brain calls
white so if you total up all the
possible signal combinations that your
brain can receive you get about 10
million different colors colors we can
summarize with cool animations like this
actually this reminds me of another
point I should probably make this isn't
actually yellow see 10 million different
colors is a lot to engineer into an LCD
screen like the one you're using to
watch this video so we've designed
screens to play tricks on your brain
your screen is made up of a bunch of
pixels if you make those pixels small
you get the illusion of a continuous
image but what if you want a color image
your eyes can only see three types of
colors red green and blue so that's all
your screen has to display red and green
set to full brightness is going to look
yellow to your brain even if it isn't
yellow if each color in the pixel has
256 different brightness levels the
screen has a total of 16,777,216
different colors it can display which is
well over the 10 million or so colors we
can see the point is we already can't
see a bunch of the colors that your
screens are displaying any additional
colors marketed to you are a complete
waste of your money so is white a real
color
not really you won't find the color
white on the visible spectrum like you
would most other colors it's not a color
connected to a single wavelength of
light but if something reflects enough
different colors at the same time all
three different types of cones will
activate at the back of your eye and
send a strong signal to your brain your
brain interprets that signal as white
your brain literally makes up colors and
white is one of those colors so are you
ever gonna look at color the same way
again please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us a special thanks goes
out to patreon patrons like William
Morton who help make this show possible
with their generous support and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy the featured comment comes
from monkey business who asked why on
earth is this not taught in school
honestly I think it's just old habits
are hard to break
also changing official curriculum is not
easy you know politics is stuff anyway
thanks for watching
[Music]